хлопцям з України
[музика]
[оплески]
україна прийм він
хотів
занесла наметом варю проектів йогорів
[музика]
тоді з 12 місяця тревор що б'ють та стояти
2pm пашки а хто такі shawnee рублик
Незрозумілий танк стоїть у бо й слава
україні
вона все зрозуміло різні вітається скажи
слово галявині ці а що він і знімати
хто там не сказавши відеозйомка
заборонено
конституції України
відеозйомка дозволено ввечері з України
[музика]
[оплески]
сам виродок з будинку з
[музика]
[оплески]
з почуттям глибокого задоволення
спостерігаю як росіяни
дуже
дорого дорогими боєприпасами з усіма
спецефектами прям з усієї
хуйней
розбирають на запчастини
абсолютно порожнє поле
я вважаю, що це геноцид
наших байбаків та мишей полевок за мене я
не можу показати де знаходиться, щоб не
пресували військовослужбовці українських
з'єднань
деякі з них здаються в полон так до
луганської народної республіки надходить
інформація що особовий склад 56
окремий бригада збройних сил
україни викинув білий прапор і віддав перевагу
здатися в полон ви чули всі 56 бригада
здалася
доброго ввечері з України
[музика]
[оплески]
ви прийшли на нашу землю за вахою ви
прийшли за кермом канал сказав візьміть
насіння покладіть сир і бачу шлях
соняшники 1 3 каталозі пляжі
[музика]
помолися пацани зламалися
можна тягнути на росію назад
[музика]
[оплески]
містичне агентство якушу що обидва
україна сподобається запрошують вас на
захоплююча та цікава дводенні
тури побачити їх і померти добро пожало
[музика]
[оплески]
доброго лікаря рамаж україна